تصعد عسكري روسي جديد ومكثف على المناطق
الرئيسيه في هذا الصراع اقصد المناطق
الاوكرانيه الشرقيه والجنوبيه ما الذي
ترمي اليه الى استراتيجيه العسكريه
الروسيه في هذه المرحله من الحرب
واضح اليوم ان هناك فشل
روسيا سريعا بعد الانسحاب من
قبل اسابيع همم ثم النجاح الاوكراني
بالوصول الى العمق الروسي عبر طائره مسيره
ثم ما ورد في تقرير
حول محمود همم في الشمال الاوكراني والتي
تجري فيها المعارك همم منذ اسابيع ولم
يستطيع الروس من الواضح الجيش الروسي
وقوات بادنر لم تستطيع ان تحقق اين نتائج
حاسمه بحيث تقول انه تم استعاده باخمود او
تم تحريرها من القوات الاوكرانيه همم هذا
همم يفسر همم الضربات الصاروخيه والطائرات
الروسيه الايراني التي يستخدمها الجيش
الروسي همم في ضرب البنا التحتيه ومراكز
الطاقه
انها بدات تتوسع باتجاه اوديس التي كانت
الى حد ما وهي الميناء الاخير همم لدى
الاوكرانيين الذي يتم من خلاله تصدير
الحبوب وفي الاتفاق والجزر اا يبدو ان
روسيا لا تملك حاليا الا هذا البعد وهو
قصف استمرار القصف بالصواريخ بعيده المد
بالتعويض همم الفشل الذي يتم عبر القوات
الروسيه في مناطق المعارك سواء في الشمال
او في المناط عمر تحدثهم عن هذا همم السعي
الروسي على تكثيف القصف لكن هناك حديث
ايضا عن جهزيه واشنطن امداد كيف بصواريخ
باتري الدفاعيه الى اي مدى قد ربما يزيد
هذه التسديد هذه الخطوه من همم
ربما قد تقرب السبل همم فالقطار
نعم اعتقد مساله التزويد اوكرانيا
بمنظومات صواريخ باتريوت المقاومه
للصواريخ الروسيه بعيده المدى اا يبدو اا
لا زال هناك تحفظات داخل الولايات المتحده
داخل الجيش الامريكي ثم ان ال المساله
حقيقه تحتاج لبيمقراطيه امريكيه في تسلسل
عمليه اتخاذ القرار لذلك راينا منذ 48
ساعه الماضيه يتم الحديث بديلا فيما يبدو
انه بديل لهذه الصواريخ لحين اتخاذ القرار
بخصوص القرار النهائي انه يجري الحديث عن
قنابل ذكيه واسلحه ذكيه ومعدات الكترونيه
متطوره يبدو ان هذه المعدات الالكترونيه
همم ستفعل فعلها بالسيناريوهات القادمه من
الحديث عن الشتاء النبي سيكون سيؤثر على
القوات الروسيه كما يؤثر على القوات
نعم لكن الحديث عن المع الاوكرانيه
بالاضافه معدات الكترونيه بالاضافه
لمعلومات استخباريه دقيقه اعتقد انها لن
تكون بصالح الروس في المدى المنظور نعم
شكرا جزيلا لك من عمان الاستاذ عمر الرداد
الخبره الامني والاستراتيجي